hundreds of thousands of uh teenagers
receiving their gcse results this
morning your message to those
who don't uh receive the increasingly
attainable higher grades
well my message to those young people is
there are lots of options available the
there's a helpline the national career
service helpline for them to that and to
to ring to find out get advice for what
to do next but there are a lot of
options
for those that don't uh get the grades
to go on to do a levels or t levels are
there all kinds of different vocational
qualifications or apprenticeships uh
that young people can consider they can
retake those gcses of course if they
wish to as well there's an autumn series
they can retake those exams in the
autumn uh if they wish to uh to take
them to take them and of course there's
an appeal process for young people who
feel that they've not been given the
right grade but today we should be
congratulating those hundreds of
thousands
of young people who have achieved so
much in very trying and difficult
circumstances over the last 18 months
and we should be paying tribute to all
those young people for what they've
achieved it's the culmination of not
just two years of the gcse course but 11
years of school education so
congratulations to everyone
who's receiving their grades today to
enable them to go on to the next phase
of their education whether that's t
levels or a levels or an apprenticeship
and also thank you to the teachers
who've done a magnificent job in
administering the teacher assessed grade
system with all the advice and guidance
that they've had from the exam boards
and the and the evidence that they've
not been uh that they have compiled to
determine the grades that have been
awarded today okay uh well given what we
saw with the a levels it looks as though
the kids will do very well 45
of a level results were either a or a
star this is gonna have to be um looked
at for next year isn't it because you
can't just have you know half of kids
getting a and a stars how do you then
differentiate between them going forward
is that something that's going to have
to be considered for next year
yes this this is an exceptional year uh
designed to to to make sure that despite
the pandemic and despite the fact that
we had to cancel exams because it
wouldn't have been fair for children
young people to sit exams and they've
had such different experiences of kovi
the different levels of self-isolation
and so on so the teacher assessed great
system is the best alternative to making
sure they can go on to the next phase of
their of their education or their
questions
but we have already with respect with
respect minister that's not my question
my question is not this year next year
you're going to have to refresh the
grading system for next year aren't you
yeah so we've already announced the the
the the adjustments to the exams we
expect all young people to be taking
exams uh in 2022 but we'll be making
adjustments to those exams to reflect
the fact that this cohort will have had
disruption to their education as well
and the regulator off quo will be saying
more about the grading standard that
will be used uh for those exams uh in
the autumn term
okay so just to clarify you will be
refreshing the grading system for next
year
no what i said was we'll be talking
about what the grading standard will be
for the 2022 exams we are looking also
in the longer term
about how to make sure that we get back
to the system we had before the pandemic
broke where we had year on year no great
inflation and we want to get back to
that system uh
in the longer run but we have to make
sure when we do that that we are fair
between different year different cohorts
of the ones that took their exams in
2020 and 2021 and the ones the students
are taking the exams in the future is
fairness that lies at the heart of any
decision uh any decisions about grading
these are very difficult decisions to
make and we will be doing so in
conjunction uh with the regulator with
the exam boards and indeed with teachers
and parents and students up and down the
country before we come to firm decisions
but but the
issue about the granting system is the
longer term we only have a limited
amount of time minister as you know and
i've allowed you very full some answers
to the first two questions you're
talking about being fair uh private
school uh pupils grades far higher than
those uh from less uh privileged
backgrounds you've been schools minister
since uh 2010
is it demoralizing for you with all the
work that you've done to close that
attainment gap to then see what's
happening
well we have closed retainment gap since
2010 by 13
in primary schools and by nine percent
and second up to the beginning of the of
the pandemic independent schools are
academically selective by and large uh
and they always do get the higher fair
higher share of top grades and this year
what we've seen is that right across the
school system whatever kind of school
the young person goes to they have seen
an increase in those top grades and if
you look at the relative change in those
top grades independent schools have gone
up by about 15 percent
comprehensive have gone up by 18 so
those top students are performing better
right across the board wherever whatever
type of school they go to but we are
determined as a government we have been
since 2010 to close that attainment gap
and that's what all our reforms have
been about the reforms to reading the
reforms to how you teach math the
changes to the curriculum in secondary
school the changes to the gcses and a
levels have all been about making sure
that every young person regardless of
their background gets the best possible
education okay minister university
students do you agree with your boss who
was on the show earlier on in the week
that they should receive a refund if
online learning continues
well what we said is that there's there
are no covet reasons now for
for students not to receive face-to-face
uh education these are matters
ultimately for for universities but
there's certainly no covered reason why
students cannot receive face-to-face
education the office for students the
regulator does monitor very closely the
quality of education
that students are receiving in our
universities and if students have
complaints they should of course
complain to the university and through
the complaints process
okay my question was should they receive
a refund your boss thinks they should do
you agree with him
well there can be that that there are
students who have gone through that
complaints procedure who have then
received conversation from the
university but these are ultimately a
matter
there are ultimately matters for the
university and we have a very powerful
regulator that gavin referred to i
understand all that i'm asking your
opinion do you agree with your boss that
kids who cannot have uh face-to-face
learning should get a refund
as i've said there is a procedure by
which they can get compensation
and that they need to go through the
complaints proceeding if the quality of
education they are receiving isn't of
the standard that is required by the
regulator okay so if that's the case and
lots of them do that who's going to pay
for the shortfall
well that will be the university sector
if they're not providing the quality of
education that the regulator requires of
them then of course the university
themselves will have to fund any
compensation payments made to to those
students but i am confident that we do
have very high quality education in our
universities we have a world-leading
university sector in this country which
we can be proud they have responded
extremely well uh to increasing numbers
of students going to university we've
seen a five percent increase last year
another five percent increase in places
this year we have record numbers of
young people going to university and
record numbers of young people from
disadvantaged backgrounds going to
university so i think we can be proud of
our university sector and what they're
doing for young people and what they're
doing for our country okay to that end
do you agree that universities should be
paying compensation for kids to defer
for 12 months so like exeter university
is offering 10 grand for some kids to do
fair for a year
well every year there are a number of
students who do a small number of
students who defer and that's the same
this year at universities we've been
working very closely
with you so you're not answering any of
my questions this morning do you think
that universities should pay students to
defer for a year
yes they can do if they wish to but
these things are always optional
for students any student that achieves i
need it on that one i just want to ask
you about your boss now um kyocera has
called for him to be sacked why do you
think he should keep his job
because he's a very effective education
secretary i've worked with gavin
williamson for the last two years and he
has driven to make sure that no student
will suffer long-term damage to their
prospect as a consequence of the
pandemic he's driven to continue the
reform program in our education system
where we're seeing up until covered we
saw that attainment gap close in primary
school and in secondary school and he's
driven to do more to make sure we
continue
to drive up standards in our education
system so that background does not
matter in terms of the opportunities
available for young people okay talk to
me about what's going on in berlin and a
british man arrested for uh spying uh
tobias elwood mp suggesting we need to
review the status of private security
personnel
do you agree
well i don't feel i'm able to talk about
this issue this is now subject
protecting the government this morning
police investigation
you're here representing the government
this morning
yes i am and because this is a matter of
police investigation it would not be
appropriate for any minister to come on
your program and to discuss this
particular issue okay i wonder if you
think that you have a view on the fact
that we don't have a security minister
that post has been open for a month uh
we should be filling that shouldn't we
given stuff like this is happening
well again this is the matter for for
the prime minister and uh he makes these
appointments and i'm sure that these
things will happen in due course okay
i'm going to ask you about the gurkhas
then has anyone from the government
spoken with representatives from the
gurkhas that are on hunger strike just
on whitehall there
well we do take very seriously the issue
of the pensions for gurkhas the gurkhas
pension scheme we've increased it
between 10 and 25 since march 2019 added
another 25 million pounds in terms of
providing health
for goku's in uh nepal
and you know ministers are of course in
touch with uh and we'll be in touch with
those people that are that are concerned
about the pensions for goku's the
gurkhas are a very important part of the
british army and we've always taken very
seriously uh the welfare and the
pensions of goku who've served in our in
our armed forces just to clarify you
said that ministers had been in touch
with them yeah
well i i'm not entirely sure who's met
who but i do know that we are always
keen to talk to people who are concerned
about the welfare of of of our of our
gurkha regiment and the and the uh and
the pensions arrangements for those for
those soldiers as i said we have been
we have increased the gurkhas pension
scheme
in march 2019 to make sure that we are
providing pensions for those
for those gurkhas who've served so well
in our armed forces indeed so 250
million quid for a boat for ministers to
travel around the world that's what the
prime minister is proposing while these
veterans are starving themselves to
death on the streets of uh whitehall the
optics are not good are they whatever
the rights and wrongs
the government has to do something about
this
and that would be a matter for the mod
in terms of wanting to sell britain
abroad it is important we are a global
trading nation
uh
and we need to make sure that we're
doing everything to sell british
business abroad and that's the purpose
of of of of of this of the kind of
projects that you're talking about
making sure that we are getting our
businesses exporting around the world uh
as we having left the european union and
that is what global britain is all about
okay quick thought before i let you go
your boss couldn't remember his a level
grades when he was asked
earlier on in the week can you remember
yours
i can yes if you uh yes i can remember
them yes go on tell
tell
me
oh well i got four four grey days and i
was able to go on to the university that
i hoped to go to and uh and and gavin
also was able to go to the university
that he
wanted to go to and he was very pleased
by his results it's great to talk to you
thanks for taking the time